المسيره الاوكرانيه تتساقط بغزاره على
الاراضي الروسيه وقوه فاغنرتو امريكا
المدفونه في اوكرانيا بينما موسكو تكشف سر
خدعه انسحاب قوه فاجنر من باخماط وامريكا
تقولها للعلن لا يوجد امام اوكرانيا الا
ان تفوض روسيا والسلاح الجو الروسي يخترق
الاجواء البولنديه ثلاث مرات متتاليه مصر
تفتح ابوابها للسودان واثيوبيا تستغل
الفوضى السوداني ومصر تتوعد بالتدخل ايران
تكشف عن سلاح جديد وسوريا تعود رسميا
للحضن العربي وتركيا ترفض طلب امريكا
ومليون وسبعمائه الف تركي يصفقون له
ساعه الصفر الروسيه
ترقب يكسوه الصمت وتفوح منه رائحه الخوف
ونقصد الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد لاستعاده
الاراضي التي اصبحت في معده الدب الروسي
توازيه تحركات عسكريه واعاده تموضع لقوات
الطرفين واجلاء لسكان بعض المقاطعات هنا
مسؤولون اوكرانيون يصدرون انذارات من
غارات جويه روسيه لمناطق تغطي ما يقرب من
ثلثي البلاد بدورها قالت قياده عمليات
الجنوب الاوكرانيه ان روسيا عززت مواقع
جنودها في البحر الاسود باربع حاملات
صواريخ من نوع كاليبار واعلنت حاله التاهب
الجوي جنوبي البلاد فيما قال عمده
ميكولايف ان الدفاعات الاوكرانيه الجويه
اسقطت مسيره روسيه وان خطر الهجمات متواصل
فيما سمع دوي انفجارات عده
وقعتون اللتين اعلنت السلطات فيهما مقتل
سته من موظف الالغام في قصف روسي بينما
قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
انها الجويه اسقطت خمسه مسيرات انتحاريه
روي
لاليت من جانب اخر اكد المدير العام
لوكاله الطاقه الذريه رافاييل جروسي البدء
باجلاء سكان من مدينه انرجي دار الاوكراني
حيث توجد محطه زابوريا النوويه وحبر جروسي
عن قلقه من تزايد الاعمال العسكريه في
منطقه المحطه التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه الرد الاوكراني جاء سريعا وبعد
استهداف الكريم للطائرات مسيره اعلن حاكم
سوفاستوبول ميخائيل روز فوجايف صده هجوم
اوكراني بالمسيارات على المدينه واضاف
الحاكم ان احدى المسيرات خرجت عن السيطره
وسقطت في منطقه غابات كما اسقطت اثنتان
منها فوق البحر
الاوكران لم يكتفوا بذلك فقد اعلن جهاز
امن الدوله الروسي احباط هجوم بمسيره
الاوكرانيه على مطار سيفرني العسكري في
مقاطعه ايفانوفو شمال شرق موسكو وقال جهاز
امن الدوله في بيان ان الهجوم كان بتخطيط
من الاستخبارات وكان الهدف منه تدمير
طائره الانذار المبكر الروسيه اي 50 واكد
جهاز امن الدوله الكشف عما اسماه المجموعه
التخريبيه التي كانت تعد لهذا الهجوم
ومنسقيها وقيادتها التي كانت تتعاون مع
الهيئات الامنيه الاوكرانيه الخاصه ومن
الهجمات الجويه الى الغنائم العسكريه ما
تشاهدونه هنا هي مركبه مصفحه امريكيه من
طرازها
في منطقه باخماط شرق البلاد مقطع الفيديو
هذا نشرته وكاله رايا نوفوسكي الروسيه
ويظهر استيلاء جنود فاغنر على المركبه
الامريكيه التي بدات معطوبه بشكل جزئي
جراء الاشتباكات الدائره مع القوات
الاوكرانيه اما بالنسبه لفاكنر التي قلبت
الموازين وبعد تصريحات رئيس مجموعه
فاغناريا بريكوجين انه يعد للانسحاب من
ضخموت وطلب استبدال قواته بوحدات عسكريه
شيشانيه ها هو يعود مجد مؤكدا انه تلقى
وعدا بالحصول على ذخائر واسلحه جديده
لاستكمال القتال في باخموت شرقي اوكرانيا
وفي ظل الترقب الغربي للهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد واشنطن بوست تكتب في طياتها ان
اوكرانيا قد تلجا للمفاوضات في حال ما
فشلت في تحقيق النجاح في المعركه المحتمله
الفشل غير مسموح به يزيلنسكي فلما ينفق
الغربيون عليك مئات مليارات الدولارات
لتبحث عن المفاوضات مجددا وهنا وبعد 12
عاما يظهر احدهم ليخبر العالم بانه كان
على علم بنيه بوتين لغزو اوكرانيا
الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق جرى حديث بينه
وبين فلاديمير بوتين عام 2011 علم خلاله
كلينتون بان غزوه اوكرانيا قادم لا محاله
حيث اعرب حينها رئيس الحكومه الروسيه
بوتين برفض بلاده لمعاهده بودافيست
الموقعه عام
1994 بشان تقديم ضمانات امنيه مقابل نقل
الموجوده في اوكرانيا الى موسكو وهل يعقل
ان كلينتون لم يخبر احدا في الاداره
الامريكيه بنيه روسيا ما رايكم انتم
وبالعوده للاجواء قالت وزاره الدفاع
الرومانيه ان طائره مقاتله روسيه اعترضت
في المجال الجوي الدولي فوق البحر الاسود
طائره بولنديه كانت تقوم بمهمه مع الوكاله
الاوروبيه لحرس الحدود والسواحل
الرد البولندي جاء عبر المتحدث باسم
الحكومه البولنديه بيوتر مولر الذي قال ان
مقاتله روسيه تواجهت مع مقاتله بولنديه
قبل يومين فوق البحر الاسود واصفا الامر
بالاستفزاز المتعمد حيث ان البلدين توترت
علاقتهما مؤخرا وذكر حرس الحدود
البولنديون ان طائره الروسيه دخلت من دون
اي اتصال لاسلكيا في منطقه العمليات التي
حددتها رومانيا ونفذت مناورات عدوانيه
وخطيره واقتربت من طائره ح رس الحدود
البولنديين ثلاث مرات من دون مسافه الامان
اللازمه ما الذي يخبئه الدب الروسي للب
ولنديانو يشتعل مجددا
مع استمرار المعارك من جهه وانطلاق
المفاوضات من جهه اخرى تتواصل موجات
النزوح من السودان حيث يشهد معبر اركين
على الحدود السودانيه المصريه حركه النشطه
للفرن من السودان الى مصر بسبب المواجهه
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
ويقدر عدد الذين عبروا منذ بدء المواجهات
بنحو 12 الف شخص من السودانيين ورعايا دول
اجنبيه وبينما يعاني السودانيون الامرين
في قلب الفوضى والحرب كشفت تقارير حديثه
معلومات عن محاوله اثيوبيا استغلال انشغال
الدول المجاوره بما يحدث في السودان من
قتال بهدف تحرك جديد بسد النهضه المختلف
عليه مع القاهره والخرطوم بالوقت الذي
كشفت معلومات اخرى عن زلزال ضرب المنطقه
فهل تكون اثيوبيا المستفيده الوحيده من
حرب السودان ام ان للجيران رايي اخر
احداث اليوم
اجرى الحرس الثوري الايراني بنجاح اختبار
صاروخ فجر 5 المجهز براس حربي حراري في
القوات البريه للحرس الثوري الى القاهره
حيث اعلن البيان الختامي الاجتماعي وزراء
الخارجيه العرب الموافقه بالاجماع على
عوده سوريا لشغل مقعدها في الجامعه
العربيه واستئناف مشاركه الوفود السوريه
في اجتماعات مجلس الجامعه اعتبارا من
الاحد اعتذر ليونيل ميسي لناديه باريس سان
جيرمان المنافس في الدوري الفرنسي لكره
القدم ولسملائه في الفريق اليوم الجمعه
بعد ايقافه بسبب قيامه برحله الى السعوديه
وغيابه عن حصه تدريبيه ابدى الاتحاد
الاوروبي صدمته من اقدام القوات
الاسرائيليه على هدم مدرسه جب الذيب
المموله من جانبه شرق بيت لحم بالضفه
الغربيه اكد وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود
جاويش اوغلو ان تركيا رفضت مقترحا امريكيا
بتسليم منظومه صواريخ الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه اس 400 لاوكرانيا
وفي تركيا ايضا نظم الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان زعم تحالف الجمهور مؤتمرا
انتخابيا في مدينه اسطنبول مع اقتراب
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه المقرره
في الرابع عشر من الشهر الجاري واكد
اردوغان ان عدد الحضور تجاوز المليون
وسبعمائه الف شخص